when he this is my little brother Luca
it's nice to meet you look good you're
under arrest
Luca what did you do what did Luca do
that's our girl pauley perrette on
tonight's NCIS
Tyler Ritter playing your little brother
Paulie right here with us how are you
doing I'm doing good and I'm really
excited for you guys to see the show
tonight it's a crossover episode with
NCIS New Orleans also all right what is
happening in the episode there was like
a plane crash and a murderer and all
this kind of stuff that happens in New
Orleans and that brings the NCIS and
NCIS New Orleans New Orleans together
and then somehow someway Abby's brother
who's a chef ends up in the middle of
all this kind of stuff
okay what is going on my apartment has
been ransacked I don't know who to trust
except you I but I know you come it's
one of the most popular shows in the
world is there any place you can go now
where people aren't like no no no I mean
it's it's a Vegas show it's been it's
been the number one drama in the world
for years and years and years and like
at some point I think it's last year
they had said that like at any given
moment there's fifty nine million people
watching in DC I asked somewhere on the
planet mm-hmm so no I can't go to work
by the way how you doing last time we
were together okay under crazy
circumstances it was crazy guy who
attacked you how are you doing yeah I am
I am physically I am fine
emotionally you know I was a very very
traumatic event you know you were with
me Kevin and I are very very different
like my my brother he's like family and
after I got attacked and he came over
it's like literally I know you were
there as my friend he told me he was
gonna kill me several times and I
absolutely believed him I can't believe
I made it out of that can't believe it
by the grace of God I did